this is a homer a basic throne shape and
it's afternoon or in the next day or so
this will go right up here that will sit
right here dead center so Daenerys will
be framed with this window and then
behind her massive great rock formation
that goes all the way up into that
corner the way it was designed the way
the light flows into that room the
throne built out of the rock it has such
a visual impact that room I think it's a
really special set by carving the throne
into that rock work itself I think makes
a very strong statement it's not a piece
of movable furniture it's something
that's tied to the building it's
something that the building was actually
built around and that was something that
was really exciting to me I'm just so
thankful that I have a throne live arm
rests on her back it's very exciting it
felt like we were doing something
special right from the beginning so when
you watch the crew walk in and when you
see their faces
its enormous ly satisfying to realize
that we got there and it worked
[Music]